Developed over the course of decades, GPS
has become far more ubiquitous than most people
realize.
Not just for navigation, its extreme accuracy
in time keeping (+/- 10 billionths of a second)
has been used by countless businesses the
world over for everything from aiding in power
grid management to helping manage stock market
and other banking transactions.
The GPS system essentially allows for companies
to have near atomic clock level precision
in their systems, including easy time synchronization
across the globe, without actually needing
to have an atomic clock or come up with their
own systems for global synchronization.
The problem is that, owing to a quirk of the
original specifications, on April 6, 2019
many GPS receivers are about to stop working
correctly unless the firmware for them is
updated promptly.
So what’s going on here, how exactly does
the GPS system work, and who first got the
idea for such a system?
On October 4, 1957, the Soviet Union launched
Sputnik.
As you might imagine, this tiny satellite,
along with subsequent satellites in the line,
were closely monitored by scientists the world
over.
Most pertinent to the topic at hand today
were two physicists at Johns Hopkins University
named William Guier and George Weiffenbach.
As they studied the orbits and signals coming
from the Sputnik satellites the pair realized
that, thanks to how fast the satellites were
going and the nature of their broadcasts,
they could use the Doppler shift of the signal
to very accurately determine the satellite’s
position.
Not long after, one Frank McClure, also of
Johns Hopkins University, asked the pair to
study whether it would be possible to do this
the other way around.
They soon found that, indeed, using the satellite’s
known orbit and studying the signal from it
as it moved, the observer on the ground could
in a relatively short time span determine
their own location.
This got the wheels turning.
Various systems were proposed and, in some
cases, developed.
Most notable to the eventual evolution of
GPS was the Navy’s Navigation Satellite
System (also known as the Navy Transit Program),
which was up and running fully by 1964.
This system could, in theory, tell a submarine
or ship crew where they were within about
25 meters, though location could only be updated
about once per hour and took about 10-15 minutes
to acquire.
Further, if the ship was moving, the precision
would be off by about one nautical mile per
5 knots of speed.
Another critical system to the ultimate development
of GPS was known as Timation, which initially
used quartz clocks synchronized on the ground
and on the satellites as a key component of
how the system determined where the ground
observer was located.
However, with such relatively imprecise clocks,
the first tests resulted in an accuracy of
only about 0.3 nautical miles and took about
15 minutes of receiving data to nail down
that location.
Subsequent advancements in Timation improved
things, even testing using an atomic clock
for increased accuracy.
But Timation was about to go the way of the
Dodo.
By the early 1970s, the Navigation System
Using Timing and Ranging (Navstar, eventually
Navstar-GPS) was proposed, essentially combining
elements from systems like Transit, Timation,
and a few other similar systems in an attempt
to make a better system from what was learned
in those projects.
Fast-forward to 1983 and while the U.S. didn’t
yet have a fully operational GPS system, the
first prototype satellites were up and the
system was being slowly tested and implemented.
It was at this point that Korean Air Lines
Flight 007, which originally departed from
New York, refueled and took off from Anchorage,
Alaska, bound for Seoul, South Korea.
What does this have to do with ubiquitous
GPS as we know it today?
On its way, the pilots had an unnoticed autopilot
issue, resulting in them unknowingly straying
into Soviet airspace.
Convinced the passenger plane was actually
a spy plane, the Soviets launched Su-15 jets
to intercept the (apparently) most poorly
crafted spy plane in history- the old “It’s
so overt, it’s covert” approach to spying.
Warning shots were fired, though the pilot
who did it stated in a later interview, “I
fired four bursts, more than 200 rounds.
For all the good it did.
After all, I was loaded with armor piercing
shells, not incendiary shells.
It’s doubtful whether anyone could see them.”
Not long after, the pilots of Korean Air 007
called Tokyo Area Control Center, requesting
to climb to Flight Level 350 (35,000 feet)
from Flight Level 330 (33,000 feet).
This resulted in the aircraft slowing below
the speed the tracking high speed interceptors
normally operated at, and thus, them blowing
right by the plane.
This was interpreted as an evasive maneuver,
even though it was actually just done for
fuel economy reasons.
A heated debate among the Soviet brass ensued
over whether more time should be taken to
identify the plane in case it was simply a
passenger airliner as it appeared.
But as it was about to fly into international
waters, and may in fact already have been
at that point, the decision was made to shoot
first and ask questions later.
The attacking pilot described what happened
next:
“Destroy the target…!”
That was easy to say.
But how?
With shells?
I had already expended 243 rounds.
Ram it?
I had always thought of that as poor taste.
Ramming is the last resort.
Just in case, I had already completed my turn
and was coming down on top of him.
Then, I had an idea.
I dropped below him about two thousand metres…
afterburners.
Switched on the missiles and brought the nose
up sharply.
Success!
I have a lock on.
Two missiles were fired and exploded near
the Boeing plane causing significant damage,
though in a testament to how safe commercial
airplanes typically are, the pilots were able
to regain control over the aircraft, even
for a time able to maintain level and stable
flight.
However, they eventually found themselves
in a slow spiral which ended in a crash killing
all 269 aboard.
As a direct result of this tragedy, President
Ronald Reagan announced on September 16, 1983
that the GPS system that had previously been
intended for U.S. military use only would
now be made available for everyone to use,
with the initial idea being the numerous safety
benefits such a system would have in civil
aviation over using then available navigation
tools.
This brings us to how exactly the GPS system
works in the first place.
Amazingly complex on some levels, the actual
nuts and bolts of the system are relatively
straightforward to understand.
To begin with, consider what happens if you’re
standing in an unknown location and you ask
someone where you are.
They reply simply- “You are 212 miles from
Seattle, Washington.”
You now can draw a circle on a map with radius
212 miles from Seattle.
Assuming the person giving you that information
is correct, you know you’re somewhere along
that circular line.
Not super helpful at this point by itself,
you then ask someone else, and they say, “You
are 150 miles from Vancouver BC.”
Now you’re getting somewhere.
When you draw that circle on the map, you’ll
see it intersects at two points.
You are standing on one of those two points.
Noticing that you are not, in fact, floating
in the ocean, you could at this point deduce
which point you are on, but work with us here
people.
Instead of making such an assumption, you
decide your senses are never to be trusted
and, after all, Jesus stood on water, so why
not you?
Thus, you ask a third person- they say, “You
are 500 miles from Boise, Idaho.”
That circle drawn, you now know exactly where
you are in two dimensional space.
Near Kamloops, Canada, as it turns out.
This is more or less what’s happening with
GPS, except in the case of GPS you need to
think in terms of 3D spheres instead of 2D
circles.
Further, how the system tells you your exact
distance from a reference point, in this case
each of the satellites, is via transmitting
the satellites’ exact locations in orbit
and a timestamp of the exact time when said
transmission was sent.
This time is synchronized across the various
satellites in the GPS constellation.
The receiver then subtracts the current known
time upon receiving the data from that transmission
time to determine the time it took for that
signal to be transmitted from the satellites
to its location.
Combining that with the known satellite locations
and the known speed of light with which the
radio signal was propagated, it can then crunch
the numbers to determine with remarkable accuracy
its location, with margins of error owing
to things like the ionosphere interfering
with the propagation of the signal, and various
other real world factors such as this potentially
throwing things off a little.
Even with these potential issues, however,
the latest generation of the GPS system can,
in theory, pinpoint your location within about
a foot or about 30 centimeters.
You may have spotted a problem here, however.
While the GPS satellites are using extremely
precise and synchronized atomic clocks, the
GPS system in your car, for example, has no
such synchronized atomic clock.
So how does it accurately determine how long
it took for the signal to get from the satellite
to itself?
It simply uses at least four, instead of three,
satellites, giving it the extra data point
it needs to solve the necessary equations
to get the appropriate missing time variable.
In a nutshell, there is only one point in
time that will match the edge of all four
spheres intersecting in one point in space
on Earth.
Thus, once the variables are solved for, the
receiver can adjust its own time keeping appropriately
to be almost perfectly synchronized, at least
momentarily, with the much more precise GPS
atomic clocks.
In some sense, this makes GPS something of
a 4D system, in that, with it, you can know
your precise point in not only space, but
time.
By continually updating its own internal clock
in this way, the receiver on the ground ends
up being nearly as accurate as an atomic clock
and is a time keeping device that is then
almost perfectly synchronized with other such
receivers across the globe, all for almost
no cost at all to the end users because the
U.S. government is footing the bill for all
the expensive bits of the system and maintaining
it.
Speaking of that maintanence, another problem
you may have spotted is that various factors
can, and do, continually move the GPS satellites
off their original orbits.
So how is this accounted for?
Tracking stations on Earth continually monitor
the exact orbits of the various GPS satellites,
with this information, along with any needed
time corrections to account for things like
Relatively, frequently updated in the GPS
almanac and ephemeris.
These two data sets are used for holding satellite
status and positional information and are
regularly broadcast to receivers, which is
how said receivers know exact positions of
the satellites in the first place.
The satellites themselves can also have their
orbits adjusted if necessary, with this process
simply being to mark the satellite as “unhealthy”
so receivers will ignore it, then move it
to its new position, track that orbit, and
once that is accurately known, update the
almanac and ephemeris and mark the satellite
as “healthy” again.
So that’s more or less how GPS came to be
and how it works at a high level.
What about the part where we said many GPS
devices may potentially stop working very
soon if not updated?
Near the turn of the century something happened
that had never happened before in the GPS
world- dubbed a “dress rehearsal for the
Y2K bug”.
You see, as a part of the time stamp sent
by the GPS satellites, there is something
known as the Week Number- literally just the
number of weeks that have passed since an
epoch, originally set to January 6, 1980.
Along with this Week Number the number of
seconds since midnight on the previous Saturday
evening is sent, thus allowing the GPS receiver
to calculate the exact date.
So what’s the problem with this?
It turns out every 1024 weeks (about every
19 years and 8 months) from the epoch, the
number rolls back to 0 owing to this integer
information being in 10 bit format.
Thus, when this happens, any GPS receiver
that doesn’t account for the Week Number
Rollover, will likely stop functioning correctly,
though the nature of the malfunction varies
from vendor to vendor and device, depending
on how said vendor implemented their system.
For some, the bug might manifest as a simple
benign date reporting error.
For others, such a date reporting error might
mean everything from incorrect positioning
to even a full system crash.
If you’ve done the math, you’ve probably
deduced that this issue first popped up in
August of 1999, only about four years after
the GPS system itself was fully operational.
At this point, of course, GPS wasn’t something
that was so ubiquitously depended on as it
is today, with only 10-15 million GPS receivers
in use worldwide in 1999 according to a 1999
report by the the United States Department
of Commerce’s Office of Telecommunications.
Today, of course, that number is in the billions
of devices.
Thankfully, when the next Week Number Rollover
event happens on April 6, 2019, it would seem
most companies that rely on GPS for critical
systems, like airlines, banking institutions,
cell networks, power grids, etc., have already
taken the necessary steps to account for the
problem.
The more realistic problems with this second
Week Number Rollover event will probably mostly
occur at the consumer level, as most people
simply are not aware of the issue at all.
Thankfully, if you’ve updated your firmware
on your GPS device recently or simply own
a GPS device purchased in the last few years,
you’re probably going to be fine here.
However, should you own a GPS device that
is several years old, that may not be the
case and you’ll most definitely want to
go to the manufacturer’s website and download
any relevant updates before the second GPS
epoch.
That public service announcement out of the
way, if you’re now wondering why somebody
doesn’t just change the specification altogether
to stop using a 10 bit Week Number, well,
you’re not the first to think of this.
Under the latest GPS interface specifications,
a 13 bit Week Number is now used, meaning
in newer devices that support this, the issue
won’t come up again for about a century
and a half.
As the machines are bound to rise up and enslave
humanity long before that occurs, that’s
really their issue to solve at that point.